good morning everyone
I'm one of those experimentalists that
you heard about yesterday I want to
thank the organizers for their generous
invitation include me in this amazing
lineup of speakers
so my lab is broadly interested in multi
neuronal dynamics at the circuit level
level of hundreds of neurons and as
we've touched on and particularly
yesterday at the end of the day the
sheer complexity of neocortex presents
really substantial experimental
analytical and theoretical challenges
for our understanding and to build
computational models that are viable so
with that in mind I'm going to start off
with this deep cut from the David Hubel
collection this is a paper that he
published in 1959 and I would just like
to start off with the title single unit
activity and striate cortex with
unrestrained cats and plis it in the
title is this idea of awake that the
cats were awake he built a micro Drive
which allowed him to isolate individual
units in visual cortex of cats he had
trained them to rest at on a table but
their heads were able to move freely and
in the paper he doesn't report this as
being a tremendous problem for keeping
his units isolated this is a case I mean
you know this unrestrained
awake behaving singly unit isolation I
mean that's still contemporary and he
was doing this at this time and this is
the first actual paragraph from the
results section so this is how he kicks
it off what he says is that there is
units that showed activity in the
absence of intentional stimulation in
the absence of visual stimuli that he
applied and this was the case when that
cat moved its eyes when the cat moved
its head when the cat had its eyes
closed whether he forced the sized
clothes or his eyes were it just blinked
and finally in total and complete
darkness and then the rest of the
manuscript he basically wrestles with
this problem because he wants to
understand visual representations at the
single unit level and yet there's all
this activity and I would argue I he and
I haven't had a heart-to-heart or
anything but I would argue he lacked the
computational resources and analytical
tools to really wrestle with this
difficulty and and so we don't currently
we no longer black computational
resources and perhaps we can take a more
informed analytical view in particular
Network science or network perspective
to the data okay so this is the goals
the goal at least as I see it is to try
to extend theories of cortical
computation from the average case to the
single trial condition using a network
based analytical set of tools and to
incorporate a more comprehensive
sampling of the system just because the
neuron isn't responding to this
particular stimulus can we still make
use of its activity to understand what's
happening in cortex I should have also
said with the Huebel experiment it was
unclear and and he called it background
activity other people have called it
ongoing activity other people have
called it spontaneous activity and most
recently I've heard someone call it's
dark activity I don't subscribe to that
one but okay
there's lots of activity now some of it
presumably is generative as we discussed
a little bit earlier on Monday and
others are multiplexed components and
you know disambiguating that is of
course a tremendous challenge all right
and I have no solution to that problem I
just I'm not trying to set myself up to
disappoint all right so this is the
outline
is going to make sure that everyone is
familiar with the tools that I'm using
what they can do and what they can't do
so I'm this talk is gonna focus on mouse
v1 we're gonna use high speed two photon
imaging and it's talked about what a
functional network is and then I'm going
to tell you that these can be used in a
really trivial manner to predict single
neuron activity on a moment-by-moment
basis and if I have time I'll go to
higher order structure I'm not sure if
that'll be the case we'll see
but minimally finally I want to jump to
assemblies at the end which is idea that
Wolfgang brought up yesterday all right
so let's get started so this is the
experimental setup we have a mouse
running on a linear treadmill
it is not compelled to do anything it's
just on the treadmill mice like to run
so they run sometimes and we're showing
drifting grading stimuli interleaved
with luminance match grace periods just
so you understand I mean it's easier to
see on the actual monitors but this is a
head bar that's clamped by these two
clamps and we're imaging through a
window and the skull okay
so how do we know where that in where
that we're in primary visual cortex we
start off by generating a retina tap the
topic map so this is a lot of asmath
from lateral to medial I mean
asmath and this is a retinotopic
intrinsic imaging basically just
reflection of a red light absorption of
red light which then allows you to
reconstruct the retinotopic map and then
finally we're going to use these blood
vessels as our fiduciary markers to do
two photon imaging so this is 800 micron
diameter window our field of view each
one of these bright punctate dots is a
neuron expressing gcamp six this is
driven by the thigh one promoter which
means that everything that I'm going to
talk to you about today is excitatory
neurons and because I'm doing planar
imaging in layer 2 3 that means that
presumably the vast majority are
pyramidal neurons and you know right ok
so what does this look like same YG camp
6 so this is one of the drifting
gratings this is the corresponding
activity in visual cortex this is not
time synchronized this is actually
collected in a raster mode where
basically the laser is placed in one
pixel and moved sequentially in a raster
mode to reconstruct the image this is
slow every time you see a neuron blink
however and this is the point of this
this is indicative of an action
potential hour or action potentials
it's obviously neurons show plenty of
sub threshold calcium fluorescence
changes but when you're imaging at this
kind of spatial resolution and you're
focusing on Samata you're seeing the
byproduct or the influx of calcium
following an action potential yes
so this is slow and this is a 2 Hertz
and I've sped it up 10 times I told you
and I started off by talking about
dynamics I care about dynamics this is
too slow to talk about dynamics so we
don't collect our data this way this is
just so I can introduce the idea that
these are indirect readouts of action
potential generation in that result from
influx of calcium okay so how do we
collect the data
okay so this is a different field of
view we automatically detect all of the
neurons we then basically solve the the
Traveling Salesman heuristic to generate
the shortest path length between all of
these points when we first developed
this we actually brute force 100 paths
98 of the hundred were optimal so we're
we do pretty well it's not very hard
it's only usually in a few hundreds of
targets and then basically what happens
is we draw we generate a line scan
through each individual neuron so we
jump from cell to cell to cell with the
single line scan through each neuron we
called it hops heuristic the optimal
path scan whatever everyone needs an
acronym okay so this is actually multi
neuronal activity also corresponding to
that same visual stimulus in this case
it slowed down five times in this case
we're imaging at for this particular
example at around 35 Hertz our scan
speed depends and corresponds directly
to the number of targets so basically we
try to cap the number of neurons I would
imagine around 350 neurons that means
we're imaging at around 30 Hertz but if
you you're number of targets we go
faster if anyone has any questions by
the way
yeah because so for the aficionados
gcamp six starts off dark almost black
actually so how do we detect them in the
first place well when the mouse is first
put on the treadmill we actually give it
a visual barrage of having a barrage of
visual stimuli thankfully - no obvious
detrimental effects and then we just do
a max projection of all the pixel values
after this barrage and then we use that
to target the neurons
so two-photon the really beautiful
advantage of it is it allows you to
densely sample your system you can look
at neurons that are immediately adjacent
to one another and resolve them as being
separate and distinct neurons of course
it's slow which is why we take this
particular approach but in this
particular case we are also limited and
by the fact that the neurons had to have
done something during this barrage of
visual stimuli I should also note that
we encourage the mouse to run during
these epochs during these barrage a--'s
and that also drives up activity making
it more likely we're able to detect
neurons this is planar imaging in layer
2 3 yeah yes
yeah so we actually have a dine we once
we've mapped out the path we draw a
contour around the individual neuron so
we know exactly when well within 16
microseconds of when we should be
entering the neuron then we have a
dynamic window basically that allows us
to just flex it a little bit and that
actually works when I first built this I
was in for in vitro imaging and when we
started doing this in vivo I was
petrified that it would not port or work
but just by having a subtly allowing
just a little bit of room of a few
samples on either side allows us to
still isolate fluorescence transients
that correspond to the neuron we did a
whole bunch of controls which I can talk
to you at length if you're interested
right right right well so when that
happens I if you have a movement
artifact it's unambiguous I mean that is
it's not a thankfully it doesn't seem to
happen very much we just have the mouse
very well clamped and we're able to do
that but as I said I'm happy to talk I'd
liked about the method okay so finally
so this is our scale bar
so every time a neuron turns red it's
been very active 250 percent change in
fluorescence if it's yellow basically
didn't respond this should and because
his response to one specific stimuli the
fact that some neurons don't respond is
a good thing
neurons some neurons respond to some
stimuli and others respond to others
okay so this is a this is one block as
we call it in the lab of visual visual
evoked activity in primary visual cortex
so these are drifting gratings
directions these are randomly ordered or
pseudo random ordered and these are
presented and five-second presentations
interleaved with three seconds of
luminance match gray and within a block
each directions repeated three times
these blocks correspond to about five
minutes of imaging time now importantly
we did at least ten blocks for each one
of our data sets so this means that
while this order is pseudo-random it's
exactly the same order for all
subsequent ten presentations of these
blocks okay this is our neurons and
these are our changes in fluorescence
that correspond as I said to some
activity action potential activity at
the bottom you'll note here that we have
rotary encoder of running speed you will
also note that there's global increases
in activity that corresponds that
running this was originally observed by
Chris Neil and the striker
and many people have reported this so
basically we did ourselves the favor of
basically by allowing them animal to run
whenever it wants we just made our lives
more difficult but okay so this is a
different way to look at the same kind
of data so now this is all 30 responses
of five example neurons to the drifting
gratings you'll note already that some
neurons show strong albeit maybe not
entirely reliable responses to specific
directions of grading and you will also
note that some neurons while they show
plenty of activity are not necessarily
locked to any one stimulus so punchline
is that these two neurons are tuned and
these three neurons are not
so this is yet another way to look at
the data I said I swear I'll stop with
this stuff in a moment but so this is
now a polar plot showing Galla a
symmetric Gaussian fit to the tuning
this neuron is strongly tuned this is
now is actually instead of multiple
neurons overlaid it's 30 all 30 trials
so this neuron as I said was strongly
tuned and this is a zoom of that of this
particular direction its preferred
direction this is trial one this is
trial 30 note that onset time of a
fluorescence change is variable from
trial to trial the amount of
fluorescence change is variable from
trial to trial and there's even trials
where there is no activation of this
particular neuron and this actually is
very consistent with what sophie was
talking about earlier that individual
neurons on their own are somewhat
unreliable and sim just like with that
talk we were very interested in thinking
about can we take a more networked
perspective to see if there's structure
and can we make sense of this oh sorry
that's one anecdote and this is all
4,500 neurons within this particular
dataset
so our untuned neurons unsurprisingly so
we're basically looking at the mean
response and asking how well does that
predict single trial responses so
variance explained and you can see that
with the untuned neurons that have no
preferred stimulus no preferred
statistical feature in the visual
stimuli this is the baseline and this is
basically what we get with a tune
neurons so in a wake ambulating mice
this is how this is what the
distribution looks like
so around 15% here but there is a fat
tail as you can see so not all neurons
are super unreliable yes
stands from the circuitry point of view
how you get a neuron this incredibly
powerful statins black-white grading and
for five seconds it's seeing this as
something sometimes just blasting along
inspiring high rates and other times
it's doing nothing do you have any sense
of why what is different about the
circuit is it some kind of a modular
Tory state that slow doing that five
second pick with all the neurons be
offer with is it completely just just a
mystery the latter we looked at all
kinds of different ways to parse the
data for instance if the example I
showed where the activity dropped out we
look to see did all than your own
stopped responding that's not the case
it's all very random so by the I should
also note that this is not the first
time this has been found in mice J
creamer from andreas toliets lab has has
this varies it's almost exactly the same
distribution essentially it's once
you're an awake ambulating Mouse anyways
very little of your single trial
response is going to be easily
explainable by the visual stimulus and
why that is it's totally unclear to me
as I said just as the Huebel paper was
wrestling with this idea of you have all
this activity and it's not easily
explainable well you know there's some
generative components this activities
are always ongoing anyways
there's also multiplexing of many
different kind of streams and I don't an
arousal changes as you said okay is your
indicator fluorescence totally reliable
that is if the cell spikes you're going
to see the flat well so I think so
personally I've wrapped on seven hundred
some-odd neurons for calibration and
other members of lab have also published
we've never seen with gcamp six a change
in fluorescence that didn't correspond
with the spike or a spike that didn't
correspond with a change in for us
but I mean no no I know I just I'm
reluctant to ever say with absolute
certainty anything's the case but I have
strong reason to believe that if there's
a change there there was spiking if
there wasn't there was no spiking maybe
maybe after a new and is activated a
certain amount of time it just has some
period to to catch its breath before
knowing that there are other neurons
that will be responding right well no
there's no there's no strong periodicity
but in terms of neurons coal burying
together yes absolutely and we'll get to
that
okay so mean squared error sorry so
we've tried different ones in the end we
used Gaussian and maybe you have 30
trials per neuron so we MA we looked at
it looks somewhat Gaussian but again you
know there's there's definitely
individual differences between neurons
okay so this is more for me and not for
you I know most people here are very
familiar this is this idea of networks
and the reason i have this up here is
kind of a disclaimer because i'm gonna
be sloppy with my nomenclature and i
apologize
oh yeah all right I better get to it all
right so we have edges which could be
connections are sorry edges or
connections in both cases I'm when I use
these words edge or connection I do not
mean a synaptic connection I'm going to
be talking purely about a relational
relationship between neurons and the
nodes are going to be neurons all right
so we're going to build a functional
Network using basically a partial
correlation coefficient so let me talk
you through this what we wanted to do is
include both the two neurons and the
untuned neurons and any functional
Network summary of the dynamics to so to
use just the standard noise correlation
measure we of course by default
throughout the untuned cells so this is
where the experimental design comes into
play we have five-minute blocks we hold
out the one that we're going to measure
our correlation and we take the mean
across all other blocks we subtract that
or remove that from this correlation
between this pairwise correlation
between these two fluorescence
transients I should have also said that
we're not doing any spike inference here
were relying on the continuous
fluorescence variable okay we also have
global changes across the whole
population that reflect running I showed
you examples of that so we're going to
take the within movie average and also
remove that and for this particular
example we end up with this weight for
the weight matrix of 0.5 this
our partial correlation between these
two this allows us to as I said to
include both the tuned and untuned cells
we then wanted to have a directed matrix
so what we did is looked at our
correlogram and looked at basically
where the max was in this particular
example the max was with zero lag so we
drew reciprocal connections asymmetric
entries in this particular weight matrix
of course if I precedes J then the entry
goes into I J and if the JB precedes I
and then it goes into J I this
particular arrangement correspond to 42%
of the entries in the weight matrix this
is what you end up with yes why partial
because of the the reasons I articulated
which is one we want to account for the
fact there's global state changes which
correspond to running which some people
have described as arousal the other
reason was because we wanted to include
the untuned neurons as well
I mean it's and also I should say we
included all the whole block right so it
wasn't just when a stimulus was
presented yes
we did not explicitly account for that
but as you can see there's many many
zero entries here gray is zero in this
weight matrix it's not organized or
ordered in any specific way we have
tuned to two tuned connections on tun
tun tun tun tun tun tun tun to tuned so
this is yes so we allowed for a few
frames so plus minus 100 milliseconds on
one side or the other no no I'm not
making there's no claims and that's why
that's why I showed the edge there's
there's no I'm not making what any
claims whatsoever about a mapping
between structure and function it's true
my group is also interested in this
general question but this is not this
story at all you know you can use you
can build these kinds of weight matrices
in many ways sometimes using spiked
inference but you know what we try to do
is always stick with the signal if we
can so this was a way to deal with all
the complexity of the of what we had and
still use a continuous variable of the
fluorescent signal and some neurons are
anti-correlated which means that
sometimes some neurons have are
responding to an orthogonal
preferentially to our thought only
presented data okay
and so that's captured here and you can
see here that we basically have the
difference in the preferred direction
this is the mean of the weights between
the tuned to tuned so you can see if
you're orthogonal e tuned you have a
lower weight than if you're and this
arrangement is not captured by the tuned
by the untuned untuned or the tuned to
okay alright so let's get to the cool
part
so so that what did we do with this wave
matrix sorry
so we have our weights which we're
pulling from the weight matrix we have
our our fluorescence transients on the
in degrees or you're going to take a
linear sum and rescale to account for
the fact that there's individual
basically number there's differences in
the numbers of inputs per neuron value
of the weights right between the two
neurons over the whole block of time
well this is sorry this is capturing
basically the weight in this matrix so
essentially what we're saying is if you
were Co active together with this amount
of reliability we're then going to
weight that rely that Co variability
with each other and in capture it in
this weight no it is number so W 1 is
the first weight W 2 all the way to
however many inputs you have this is the
neuron we want to model or actually but
not neuron is here that's right we're
gonna take the in degrees I'm sorry that
I wasn't precise thank you for helping
me clarify that okay so we do
surprisingly well with this really
trivial kind of model so this is the
predicted activity as compared to the
measured activity obviously it's not
perfect but we're capturing a lot of the
fluctuations so just so that you know
that I'm not just cherry picking them
one and only example that worked this is
the distribution of all 4,500 neurons
this is our now our mean squared error
this is the neuron this is this pair
right here or
I should say this is this neuron that we
model and we're comparing it to the
optimal so what is optimal so in this
case let's just talk about variance
explained the best we can do by
regressing the optimal weights is around
92% variance explained and with mean of
around remember 80 percent or so with
the with the inferred weights we do
about 10 percent less on both of those
measures so we're not optimum or close
to optimal now the last thing I want to
say about this is we actually held out
one block of the data so we we built a
functional network using basically nine
blocks meaning 45 minutes of data and
modeled the fifth other five held out
minutes of data and we there's a
decrement of an additional 10% from
optimal so okay so this and just to just
to reinforce the fact we are actually
modeling moment-to-moment this is not
just an average this is we're literally
each time step we generate a new
fluorescence transient a model the
fluorescence transient so thank you for
that the red is unto neurons the blue
are two neurons that are already
connected to it yes so what would be the
optimal weights essentially
Jason to the optimal ones do better than
the partial correlations ones because
they are allowed to take into account
stimulus information that you so
presumably that's the case although I
can't say with absolute certainty that's
the case I mean by definition our
inferred weights are basically we've
technically removed the signal
correlation now of course there's signal
in the fluorescence transients that
we're putting into the model so I'm not
saying so it's not this perfect
separation and making making it somewhat
I mean making this distinction so it's
somewhat tricky yeah no thank you
okay so how am i doing on time any more
minutes okay so this is actually in some
ways speaking to this point so we're
able to use the fluorescence transients
build a prediction a model of individual
neurons responses and then we're able to
put put it back through our pipeline of
tuning and what we see is that we have
do really well so we gain the ability in
some ways to predict moment to moment
activity and we're still able to recover
tuning within this system okay so what
are determinants for how well we do with
our modeling one is sample size so the
more neurons that we sampled generally
with one exception the better we do with
basically our reconstructions so yeah
this this brings up something that I'm
always curious about which is what's the
optimal sample size I mean these are
trivial stimuli this is not hard
stimuli for the system yes
how the error is spatially distributed
within your window I'm wondering if
you're able to predict the
closer to the centre better right this
is a great question this is about again
speaking to sampling so there's only
there's not really any relationship with
space but there is a relationship with
how clustered the neurons were meaning
basically how many inputs were we able
to use them do a model but yes
okay the other thing is that large
weights unsurprisingly contribute
disproportionately to prediction
accuracy and you can see that here
especially this is us we're moving the
strongest edges first this is our
decrement in and reconstruction mean
squared error increases as we move and
this is our fraction of weight removed
here so and this is relevant in the
sense that in part because the recurrent
connections are biased toward large edge
weights so meaning that if we're
removing this largest weights from the
model we're disproportionately removing
the recurrent connections so there this
is again about this system being Co
active together in Kovarian together
okay so for the sake of time I'm just
going to skip past this and just if
you're interested it's up on bio archive
and I want to oh so I'm gonna summarize
here and within because I didn't show
you this I'm not going to say that but
basically neurons are variable making
predictions about the single trial
activity from tuning properties
difficult at least in mice that are
awake and ambulating this is absolutely
the case
building the functional networks using
these partial correlation values as
weights and then providing direction
based on the cross correlogram were able
to achieve near optimal predictions of
basically moment-to-moment fluorescence
Tran transients this is a very network
perspective as I said it's not about an
individual neuron and we're also able to
predict the single neuron tuning however
from this information okay now one of
the things that I've been preoccupied
with over the last few years is this
idea of assemblies so how am I thinking
about this and what do I think this what
I just showed you how does this inform
or contribute to this discussion so I
would say that the data demonstrates
that there's this loose coalition of
neurons that Co activate or co-vary
together with with one another and
they're consequently predictable with of
one another so in other words you have a
collection of neurons that are going to
Co very multi neuronal activity shows
pairwise timing differences as indicated
by the fact we don't have a symmetric
weight matrix are not predominant not
overwhelmingly symmetric matrix and so
basically there is a spatial temporal
component to this representation of or
building this act building basically
whatever neuron is going to do in any
given time but there's also very more
many unknowns so how large numerically
should a assembly be how long does it
last
is this a useful thing from a
computational perspective
you know the data doesn't tell us and
I'm really excited about this idea of
the spiking network models being used to
kind of explore these ideas particularly
as they relate to computing what size
should be thinking about okay and then
with that I'll just the work was done by
Jody tree and my look at the
distribution of any of these behaviors
as a function of Halton they were right
so well one thing that I skipped over is
that both tuned and untuned edges
contribute to accurate reconstructions
and for both classes of cell so meaning
that they're not mutually exclusive the
second thing is how Tunes you are we
kind of looked at it in the following
way and we said okay with the most tuned
neurons do they provide particularly in
are they particularly informative about
reconstruction of the next neuron
downstream in the functional Network and
in fact there was no correlation
whatsoever with your tuning and your
contribution to accurate reconstructions
yeah I was just at a meeting actually I
flew here from Frankfurt and everyone
was talking about spontaneous activity
and it was kind of a weird thing because
I was really interested in that for a
while and then no until everyone told me
they didn't care so the short answer is
we haven't looked at it I'm really
excited to look at it we don't actually
didn't build it into this particular
experiment but I do think it would be
very informative because it would set a
kind of a baseline set of expectations
what kind of correlational structures
manifest within the population
independent of stimulus and bringing it
back to this generative component was
pretty excited about them there was
nothing special about them I mean at
least within this context I mean these
are really trivial visual stimuli we're
not asking the system to do anything
very interesting so maybe maybe if
stimuli get more rich and things like
that which is one thing that we're doing
now the negative ways will become much
more interesting so which part is
surprising here that you can do was sort
of so few nerd 50 nerds you're probably
maybe getting 35 even why did it why was
I surprised I was surprised that it was
such a simple model because we're
missing so much as you said
well so that I mean leave my group has
looked at this question a lot how much
could you even hope for and assuming
that you have a large diversity of
visual stimuli this is in model and then
we also did it in with paired
patch-clamp recordings in slices the
basically the best you're ever going to
do is between eight to twelve percent of
the neurons are even have a likelihood
or a high likelihood of being
synaptically connected so your estimate
is right on but yeah we haven't really
thought about the mapping between the
two yet although that's I think a really
exciting an interesting topic yes that
is correct you know where cells are
linear oriented and you have a very over
complete representation you know what's
a Berkeley two neurons activity to a
very simple stimulus can be predicted by
a large population of surrounding
neurons that have very heavily
overlapping receptive field he's an
orientation in position as you know so
the linear combination of those
activities I mean I would have thought
would have been an excellent predictor
that was a good sign
yes you can I thought it was an
excellent predictor I mean I said
surprise were delighted that this was an
excellent prediction maybe it would be
good to take a like the standard kind of
you know off-the-shelf model of v1
pictures to integrating and then see how
well you could predict a good more
function and normalizing a more
functions activity from surrounding
similarly oriented in the position cells
300 of them and see if that doesn't also
work very well with just a linear
combination with single layer of weights
essentially I guess say it seems like it
well I mean it did and so I'm glad that
it did otherwise you'd be disappointed I
mean so it's a good point I would say I
don't know how to accurately model v1
frankly I mean and so I assume also I
could show it I and push it in different
ways and and you know so it's under
constraint and so we're actually going
in a different way and thinking about
basically these more complex stimuli and
seeing if if basically there's more rich
detail that we could extract for
instance where it's not necessarily
straightforward or obvious about how you
build up to you take these kinds of
arrangements and build up to a
representation of a more much more
complex stimuli where it's not just a
highly salient visual drifting grating
yes
yeah I I mean this is all they are two
three
as I said presumably some of it is the
direct result of flama cortical inputs
but most of it's going to be kind of the
forward of two three yeah I would love
to have access to that I actually I'm
also very interested in interneurons all
this is excitatory the negative edge
weight is indicative of a negative
correlation this is not it should not be
interpreted as inhibition it is
certainly not inhibition and I would
like to be able to start dropping in an
informed way interneurons into these
weight matrices but you know so that's
another thing that we're working on
right now
so I guess I I wish I could do that and
then see but anyways
I think thats related to part of this
question you found though that only a
tiny fraction of the cells responses is
predictable from the stimulus variable
right and that is correct so when you're
sampling the neighboring cells and
making a predictive model what is it
about those neighboring cells activity
that you think is actually driving the
predictability of the response in the
downstream cell it seems like it can't
be they're tuning because they're tuning
right right no it's not okay so it's not
the running because we purposely remove
that component from our at least from
the model not from what we put into the
model yes yes okay so what I would say
is the following is that only part of
what a mouse B one is doing and at least
in response to drifting grading is
representing that drifting grading all
right and I think actually the why so
the way I see it is that the circuit the
neurons that you covary with ie this the
assembly is the thing that's
particularly informative about what
you're going to do regardless of a
direct synaptic connection again I want
to be hopefully I've driven that point
home this is correlation essentially
there's nothing or not like literally
just this specific form of it so I'm so
presumably whether it's through common
drive or literally synaptic connection
you are Co varying as a circuit as a
network representation and there's their
structure there which is informative
about what each individual neuron will
do
oh you mean this idea of a
longitudinally robust weight matrix so
each day was treated as a separate day
we did although you can return to the
same neurons day after day with some
fidelity I mean you you're never going
to get exactly a hundred percent of the
same neurons every single day we haven't
yet explored that but I I agree it's a
very interesting question okay thank you
very much
[Applause]